this episode was made possible by
Skillshare home to over 20,000 classes
that could help teach you a new life
skill humans are really really good at
killing each other for thousands of
years we've come up with more and more
efficient methods of wiping our enemies
off the map the invention of the atomic
bomb was seen as a turning point a
moment in history where people stopped
and thought maybe this isn't such a good
thing unfortunately it was too late to
turn back we had open Pandora's box and
even now years after humanity stood at
the brink of total destruction during
the Cold War we have huge stockpiles of
nuclear weapons ready to be launched at
a moment's notice
however with recent talks of
denuclearizing the Korean Peninsula
things are beginning to look up knock on
wood if North Korea did decide to give
up their nukes and other countries
decided to follow suit what would happen
we can't exactly just leave these things
in a big pile somewhere what do we do
with thousands of the most destructive
weapons ever devised on the bright side
there are actually far fewer nuclear
weapons in the world stockpiles than
there have been in the past during the
fear and uncertainty of the Cold War the
world's nuclear arsenal had snowballed
to almost sixty four and a half thousand
mostly thanks to the standoff between
the United States and the Soviet Union
neither wishing to be outgunned by the
other thankfully we avoided extinction
and have since dismantled or retired a
large portion of these doomsday weapons
mostly from the American and Russian
stockpiles and we now only have to worry
about 15,000 of them so what do we do
with unwanted nukes there are currently
two official actions a nation can take
to reducing their nuclear stockpile
first there's retirement this is a more
temporary solution as the weapons aren't
completely taken apart but rather kept
in a storage facility for a rainy day
they are no longer part of the official
arsenal but they still exist in a very
real way the way retirement typically
works is that the warhead the actual
scary bit of the weapon is removed from
its delivery system after which other
so-called limited life components such
as tritium bottles and neutron
generators are separated from the bombs
and the remaining warhead assembly is
stuffed in a Depot somewhere to await
complete destruction or not the second
more definitive option is complete
dismantlement which can be rather tricky
depending on whether the weapon is
powered by uranium or plutonium nations
have to take different
courses of action to render the weapons
inoperable or safe for other less
destructive applications in the United
States nuclear warhead dismantlement
takes place at the pantex plant located
in the Texas Panhandle the warheads are
taken to an underground bunker where
they're carefully taken apart some of
the valuable metals such as gold and
copper are then recycled and the high
explosive components are incinerated and
the resulting a ship to an epa-approved
disposal site the uranium bearing
components are then shipped to another
location in Oak Ridge Tennessee uranium
is a naturally occurring element that's
enriched to form the heart of many
nuclear weapons the nice thing about
uranium is despite its potential for
incredible destruction it does have
Taymor uses the weapons-grade uranium
from dismantled warheads can be mixed
with lower grade uranium to make it
ready for use in civilian nuclear power
plants where it can use its powers for
good instead of evaporating entire
cities plutonium on the other hand is
just bad news all around as of right now
aside from powering a handful of space
probes there's not a single use for
plutonium besides as a component in
nuclear weapons it can't be broken down
or blended into a safer form which means
it's always ready to be used in a nuke
unlike uranium plutonium is not
naturally occurring but it does require
less of it to make a functioning bomb
which is why it's sometimes seen as the
preferable ingredient in nuclear weapons
even separated from its delivery system
plutonium will remain dangerous for a
very long time it's half-life the time
it takes for half of its radioactive
material to decay is 24,000 100 years
radioactive contaminants are dangerous
for ten to twenty times their half life
meaning plutonium in the environment
today will be a risk for the next half a
million years in order to best mitigate
the risk of our existing plutonium the
only real solution we found is to bury
it underground in special containment
facilities and ignore it for the rest of
time it will never be truly safe but
it's the best we can do while keeping it
on earth but what about off earth many
people wonder why we can't just load our
radioactive material into rockets and
blast them into the Sun it sounds nice
in theory but think about that for a
moment who in their right mind would
want to be anywhere near that launch pad
what happens if the rocket malfunctions
and crashes or blows up high in the air
and scatters radioactive material for
miles not a good day to say the least if
we did manage to get
rocket into space it would actually be
more difficult to send it into the Sun
than it would be to set it on a course
out of the solar system
okay so send it into deep space
technically it's possible but it would
be exponentially more expensive than
something like sending it into low-earth
orbit we're talking many many tens of
billions of dollars then there's the
legal dilemma of the fact that no one
country owns space meaning everyone
would have to agree on the plan and then
the ethical dilemma of what might happen
to some poor unsuspecting planet at some
far distant point in the future so
really the best case scenario is
rehabilitating all our uranium to be
used in civilian power plants carefully
storing all our existing plutonium deep
underground in uninhabited areas and
throwing away the key and never
producing another nuclear warhead ever
again is that a likely reality maybe
maybe not
but we've already made great strides in
reducing the world's nuclear stockpile
and the future looks brighter with every
treaty signed and every agreement
reached if there's anything we humans
are good at it's learning from our
mistakes and learning in general
specifically with Skillshare if you want
to learn a new skill to market yourself
start a YouTube channel like I did or
just become a better version of you I
highly recommend you check out
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators with
over 20,000 classes in graphic design
business technology and more I'm
actually in the process of creating my
own introduction to photography course
which will hopefully be ready in the
next few weeks so stay tuned a premium
membership gives you access to tons of
awesome classes that can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities and help
you do the work you love join me and the
millions of other students on Skillshare
today with a special offer just for you
guys you can get your first two months
of Skillshare for free by signing up
using the link below so if you want
access to over 20,000 classes to start
learning your awesome new skill
make sure to visit skill share by
following the link below if you enjoyed
this video consider subscribing and
clicking the bell to support the channel
if you're not sure what to watch next
check out these playlists full of other
great content as always thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week